we're talking about the fate of a whole  planet why are people so polite why are  they so patient why are they so  forgiving of gangsterism and betrayal  it's very difficult to understand I  believe it's because the dominator  culture is increasingly more and more  sophisticated in its perfection of  subliminal mechanisms of control and I  don't mean anything grandiose and  paranoid I just mean that through press  releases and sound bites and the  enforced idiocy of television the the  drama of a dying world has been turned  into a soap opera for most people and  they don't understand that it's it's  their story and that they will eat it in  the final act if somewhere between here  and the final act they don't stand up on  their hind legs and howl